[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos atentos a esta pregunta si
pudierais escoger entre vivir la vida de
una de las personas más ricas y
poderosas del mundo hace trescientos o
cuatrocientos años como por ejemplo
podría ser george washington o por el
contrario vivir la vida de hoy de una
persona normal y corriente una persona
de clase media en países como nueva
zelanda dinamarca o canadá con que os
quedaríais esto es la pregunta más
difícil que me han hecho a lo largo de
todo en mi vida político puede que
muchos tengáis la tentación de responder
muy rápido que sin duda alguna de poder
escoger os quedaríais siempre con la
vida del más pudiente del más rico
verdad pues si habéis escogido esa
opción amigos no tengo nada claro que lo
hayáis pensado bien me explico aceptar
la vida de una de esas súper fortunas
históricas os supondría renunciar a
cosas tan elementales como el aire
acondicionado internet los teléfonos
móviles el cine la pizza y bueno
prácticamente cualquier cosa que hoy
consideramos indispensable en nuestras
vidas
[Música]
y por supuesto tendríais también que
aceptar una esperanza de vida mucho pero
que mucho más corta fijaos por ejemplo
en la descripción que el economista
xavier sala i martín hace de la vida de
mansa musa primero de mal y que ojo a
precios actuales es considerado como la
persona más rica de todos los tiempos
mansa musa tardó varios meses en
recorrer a caballo los 5.000 kilómetros
que separan malí de la meca un viaje que
en un avión moderno se realiza hoy en
unas seis horas y media sus palacios no
tenían aire acondicionado no tenían
acceso a google y sus hijos por supuesto
no podían jugar con la playstation o la
wii para comunicarse con su colega del
sultán al nasir de el cairo mansa musa
no tenía whatsapp ni facebook ni
teléfono móvil por supuesto nunca pudo
tomarse una aspirina cuando tenía dolor
de cabeza xavier sala i martín profesor
de economía en la universidad de
columbia y no penséis que hace 100 años
la cosa era mucho mejor por aquel
entonces john rockefeller el conocido
magnate del petróleo no podía ver la
tele
y escuchar la radio ni usar antibióticos
todos estos lujos simplemente no
existían sí así es amigos yo lo tengo
claro de poder escoger me quedo con la
vida de clase media de nuestros días
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nada de viajes al pasado y eso de que
los tiempos pasados fueron siempre
mejores pues como que no claro que a
decir verdad todo esto tampoco puede
sorprendernos al fin y al cabo la
innovación y el desarrollo tecnológico
han sido siempre uno de los principales
motores para mejorar la calidad de vida
de todas las personas
muy bien respecto a todo esto tengo una
buena noticia y también lo siento una
mala la buena es que todo apunta a que
estamos a las puertas de una nueva época
de cambios revolucionarios cambios
propios de las novelas de ciencia
ficción
coches y camiones que conducen solos
biotecnología robótica nanotecnología
inteligencia artificial o simplemente la
capacidad de compartir masivamente el
conocimiento a través de la nube en los
próximos años todo apunta a que vamos a
poder experimentar muchos pero que
muchos cambios en nuestras vidas y la
mala noticia amigos es que por otro lado
muchos expertos afirman que tanto la
velocidad como la profundidad de los
cambios se están ralentizando desde hace
décadas es decir que todos estos
milagros tecnológicos podrían tardar
mucho en llegar o incluso no hacerlo
nunca
[Música]
el frenazo
los últimos 20 años del siglo 19 y los
primeros 50 del siglo 20 fueron algo así
como la edad dorada de la innovación los
cambios que se produjeron en esas pocas
décadas fueron tan grandes que incluso
hoy parecen una especie de milagro
fijaos en ese tiempo se desarrollaron
tecnologías como el automóvil los
aviones los antibióticos la electricidad
la energía nuclear los insecticidas y
una larga pero que muy larga lista de
cosas que cambiaron por siempre la vida
del ser humano los lavadores donuts y
que había en órbita poseen apertura toma
automática filtro anterior y completa
programación de lavado tantos cambios
consiguieron que en poco más de 50 años
la humanidad pasará de moverse a caballo
y ojo cuando se tenía la fortuna de
tener uno a visitar ni más ni menos que
la luna
solar
[Música]
no no
fijaos en la evolución por ejemplo de
los aviones que pasaron de ser algo así
a principios del siglo 20 a cosas así en
la década de los 50
[Música]
o echemos un vistazo a cómo han cambiado
los coches así eran al principio y así
en los años 50
[Música]
por pensar incluso podemos pensar en el
microondas una tecnología que en poco
tiempo pasó de ser una teoría a ser
utilizada en grandes paneles de radar y
finalmente a estar en las cocinas de
prácticamente todas las casas
también la luz que pasó de las velas a
las bombillas la farmacia con el
descubrimiento de los antibióticos las
comunicaciones donde en poco tiempo se
pasó de la paloma mensajera al telégrafo
primero y al teléfono poco después en
otras palabras hablamos de un desarrollo
impresionante sin embargo desde entonces
bueno digamos que las cosas han mejorado
pero tampoco tanto
[Música]
los aviones siguen siendo básicamente
los mismos aviones más seguros más
capaces y más confortables eso sí pero
básicamente hablamos de la misma
tecnología mejorada de hecho podemos
decir que el único campo donde se han
producido muchas innovaciones
disruptivas ha sido en el mundo digital
así que amigos la pregunta que tenemos
que responder es qué ha pasado porque en
el mundo digital las cosas van a toda
máquina y en otros campos no tanto pues
algunas personas como peter thiel lo
tienen muy claro atentos creo que hemos
tenido mucha innovación en computadoras
tecnologías de la información internet
internet móvil en el mundo de los bits
no tanto en el mundo de los átomos
viajes supersónicos viajes espaciales
nuevas formas de energía medicina
etcétera etcétera
yo diría que vivimos en un mundo en el
que los bits no fueron regulados
mientras que los átomos sí fueron
regulados un momento está diciendo peter
thiel que algunas malas regulaciones
están frenando la innovación pues sabéis
que no es el único
[Música]
no son pocos los expertos que defienden
que la innovación lleva años
enfrentándose a lo que podríamos
denominar como una tormenta casi
perfecta
una tormenta compuesta entre otras cosas
por exceso de regulaciones
armonizaciones patentes y mucha
demasiada prudencia y ojo amigos porque
cuando hablamos de frenar la innovación
tenemos que ser claros hablamos ni más
ni menos que de frenar el progreso
ralentizar o frenar tecnologías que
podrían mejorar mucho nuestras vidas
desde la cura contra el cáncer a quien
sabe vuelos espaciales
paralizados por el miedo
[Música]
es verdad la regulación suele tener como
objetivo mejorar la seguridad y la
calidad de vida para los ciudadanos pero
unas cosas son los objetivos y otra los
resultados no pocas veces los políticos
se olvidan que las regulaciones también
tienen consecuencias negativas y desde
luego si hay muchas regulaciones las
consecuencias pueden ser muy negativas
echemos un vistazo por ejemplo a lo que
ocurre con la investigación farmacéutica
en la unión europea que desde luego en
materia de regulaciones es toda una
campeona mundial
todos sabemos lo importante que es la
investigación médica y farmacéutica y
cómo puede mejorar nuestras vidas pues
bien la enorme regulación hace que
desarrollar un nuevo medicamento pueda
costar más de diez años y no sólo
hablamos del tiempo que le supone a los
laboratorios cumplir con toda la
normativa sino que incluso cuando
finalmente obtienen la autorización de
la agencia europea de los medicamentos
aún tienen que esperar por culpa de la
burocracia un año más para llevar su
producto al mercado
y amigos todo esto claro tiene
consecuencias por un lado retrasa
muchísimo los procesos de innovación que
en gran medida no lo olvidemos se basan
en la experiencia por otro encarece
mucho la investigación claro es que
hablamos de 10 ó 12 años invirtiendo
mucho dinero y sin posibilidad de ganar
absolutamente nada
[Música]
ojos y está claro la prudencia y
garantizar la seguridad es algo muy
importante pero 10 o 12 años por culpa
de una burocracia excesiva puede amigos
que nos estemos pasando
y luego hay otro detalle que no podemos
olvidar el privilegio de monopolio que
de alguna forma
todas estas regulaciones crean para las
grandes multinacionales farmacéuticas
tal cual como lo escucháis las grandes
beneficiadas por todas esta híper
regulación son precisamente las grandes
farmacéuticas claro si los pequeños
laboratorios no pueden hacer frente a
todos estos costes y el mercado cambia
menos porque hay menos innovación pues
digamos que las grandes tienen un
negocio seguro bien grande y estable
pero no es sólo la industria
farmacéutica para nada la de los
juguetes o la industria agrícola también
se ven muy afectadas por ejemplo y
además está también la inseguridad
jurídica que supone invertir mucho
dinero en un proyecto de investigación a
diez años vista y que de repente se
aprueben nuevas regulaciones que cambian
las reglas del juego
insisto muchas regulaciones son
importantes pero hay que tener mucho
cuidado con la hiperregulación porque
cuando sumamos muchas exigencias al
final lo que hacemos es encarecer y
frenar el proceso que más mejora la vida
de todas las personas la innovación
jones
[Música]
otro buen ejemplo lo tenemos con la
tecnología móvil sabíais que ya en los
años 40 comenzó a desarrollarse esta
tecnología sí así es todo esto de la
comunicación móvil no es tan nuevo como
parece en la década de los 40 comenzó a
desarrollarse el mts el servicio de
telefonía móvil un estándar que utiliza
ondas de radio para conectar un teléfono
fijo con otro móvil pero claro puede que
os estéis preguntando qué diantres paso
para que esta tecnología tardase tanto
en madurar al fin y al cabo no fue hasta
finales de los 80 cuando aparecieron los
primeros teléfonos móviles modernos y
hasta finales de los 90 cuando empezaron
a popularizarse pues la respuesta amigos
pasa por la clase política y las
regulaciones
[Música]
racing
pero es básico administrar sus propias
mente y su regular veréis la comisión
federal de comunicaciones de eeuu
administra por ley y concede las
licencias para usar el llamado espectro
radioeléctrico esto es el medio por el
cual se transmiten las ondas de radio
electromagnéticas es decir las señales
que permiten las telecomunicaciones pues
bien mirar lo que pasó
cuando las empresas estaban invirtiendo
en desarrollar la tecnología móvil allá
por los años 50
esta comisión federal de las
comunicaciones al fin y al cabo un
órgano político decidió que todo eso de
la telefonía móvil no era muy importante
y que el espectro radioeléctrico tenía
que usarse para potenciar otra
tecnología naciente la televisión que
era mucho más sutil esto bueno ya es
algo que puede ser discutible pero el
caso es que se asignó mucho espectro a
las televisiones bastante más de lo que
necesitaban
[Música]
y vamos que lo cierto es que las dos
tecnologías hubiesen podido
desarrollarse al tiempo pero el
regulador los políticos simplemente no
le vieron futuro a esto de las
comunicaciones móviles
y ahí no acaba todo en 1973 el
vicepresidente de motorola
martin cooper que es considerado el
padre del teléfono móvil hizo la primera
llamada con uno de estos dispositivos
que hoy todos conocemos si en los años
setenta pero una vez más amigos
intervino el regulador que consideraba
que bueno que en esto de la telefonía
móvil la competencia no era posible y
había que asignarle el monopolio al
américa en telecom
para entendernos podemos decir que los
políticos no vieron ni una y retrasaron
más de 40 años en el desarrollo de las
comunicaciones móviles esto era en eeuu
pero es que en europa bueno la cosa en
general transcurría por un camino muy
similar
y todo esto es normal amigos porque la
investigación y la innovación es cosa de
científicos y emprendedores no de
políticos un incremento presupuestario
dotado con 800 millones de euros para
los cuatro años que nos hace hablar de
un plan de y más de makin ambicioso con
capacidad para enfrentarse a los retos
que la sociedad actual 12 mal da de
hecho este es el problema de muchos de
los programas de i + d + y públicos que
no funcionan porque su trabajo viene
determinado por políticos y burócratas
luego es contado aquí en visual político
los gobiernos pueden jugar un papel
destacado en promover la i + d + y pero
lo tienen que hacer siendo conscientes
de sus limitaciones
[Música]
es lo que hicieron en israel con el
programa george man lo hemos visto aquí
darle el liderazgo a los inversores a
los emprendedores y a los científicos
que operan en un mercado en competencia
si no se hace esto los programas y las
ayudas públicas pueden ser incluso
contraproducentes pueden elevar los
costes de la y más demás y dificultar la
tarea de las startups y en definitiva
frenar el desarrollo tecnológico y la
innovación que son las mejores formas de
incrementar la calidad de vida de todos
nosotros pero dicho esto turno para ti
qué países piensas que liderarán la
carrera tecnológica déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si te ha resultado interesante
este vídeo dale al botón de like y
ayúdanos a compartirlo por cierto muchas
gracias a nuestro amigo víctor quien nos
ha ayudado un montón con la preparación
de este vídeo víctor gracias ahora sí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
ah
y mente